hey gang it's your old pals uncle hank
and kippy just want to thank you for
tuning in to ru garbage
yeah guys make sure you subscribe that
way you get the episode as they come out
you can also go to gasdigitalnetwork.com
use promo code ayg
to get bonus content and get the
episodes before they come out and hd
streaming
do it yeah welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy
individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan
and h foley
baby hey everybody out there and welcome
back to everybody's favorite new podcast
this is are you garbage the show where
you sit down with your favorite
comedians
and find out if they grow up classy or
if they're absolute trash i'm your host
stage foley coming at you on a glorious
day here in the east village new york
city
gas digital studios let me [ __ ] put
the rumors to bed gang the city ain't
[ __ ] dead
i'll tell you that right now we're
taking the [ __ ] city back starting
today
i don't care who wrote an op-ed my
co-host coming at you from right next to
me my old pal gang
next time you reach for a best pal folks
make it a kippy he tastes great he's
less filling and he's easy on the eyes
give it up for kevin james ryan
everybody double the forehead everybody
hey what's up happy to be here thanks so
much for listening guys
also thank you everybody bought a shirt
for the pre-sale we appreciate that
moved
a couple of digits in the shirt
so appreciate that if you haven't
already please make sure you rate review
subscribe on itunes
also full video available on youtube you
can subscribe there as well
yes sir and gang we could not i mean
could not be more excited to have our
very special guest with us
in studio today he is an extremely
successful
broadcaster blogger podcaster he is the
host of we gotta believe
and of course the host of kfc radio on
barstool
but the big question about his mind
today is he garbage i don't know
i gotta tell you i don't know about that
but he's a tall drink of water and he's
got a great [ __ ] head of hair
this guy should be drinking an apparel
spritzer at the [ __ ] regatta he's got
a little island
good quaff on the kid ladies and
gentlemen
give it the [ __ ] up for the one the only
kfc himself mr
kevin clancy you guys know the key to my
heart man
swooning over here look at that look at
that dental work too this kid's got a
fresh set
yeah are those veneers yeah four front
four all fake
when did you get veneers you didn't get
them when you were young you got them
like when things started
no no i actually uh i was i was like 18
probably wow
so i i kept uh i played basketball and i
was like kind of an idiot i was a kid
and i kept
chipping these two teeth and breaking
them and i was like i don't really care
my mom
maybe this leads into whether i'm
garbage or not she was like we can't
have you walking around like disgusting
yeah basically they start calling you a
cousin
veneers at 18. that's that's my first
move i get on
i'm going to get a [ __ ] fresh pair
gotta fix the tv he's been so
hard he's been man he's been saying that
since i met him i want to set up
yeah give me the big boys
buddy thanks so much for coming in
thanks for having me this is a great
setup i i'm looking forward to it
because i know you guys
did uh kate and then feidelberg yeah and
so uh and federal
came in well it's wrong that he was not
garbage like we didn't even ask him he
goes i'm going on record that i'm not
garbage what was your guy's
determination on that one final answer
i think i hit him at like six yeah two
percent
garbage he's like uh he himself is like
a garbage pail like exhausted his family
is classy he comes from good stock but
when he starts making decisions talk
about black sheep
he what he pissed his pants at work the
other day geez we did we did this
we got this guy who was drunk uh well
usually
that yes those were separate we have
this guy uh
vibs who does this show called laura in
the bar where he sits at the bar at the
office
and he makes us eat disgusting [ __ ]
disgusting challenges
and this time it was a little nitro
gummy bear nine million on the scoville
units long story short it was so hot
vital break pisses pants
jesus it ruined us for like all of us
like for like a few days
i would have taken a sick day yeah we
did i mean it was ugly it was ugly
i want a pack of gummy bears now i don't
know about you boys that sounds good
tell us the back story a little bit i'm
not really thinking i don't think i know
you're a new york guy new york guy born
and bred
you're a mets fan you're a mets fan um
i've been uh i lived behind enemy lines
my whole life i was born in the bronx
okay uh my dumb ass mother and
grandfather
gave me this curse of being a mets fan
uh so yeah i was born in uh the bronx in
city island
uh which is a weird place i don't know
if you're familiar with it yeah like
what the [ __ ] i know it's
like city island it's like the the land
that like time forgot you know it's just
out on this island and it's like
it's a bizarre place uh then i did a uh
uh i did a bid outside of philly for a
little bit my dad got a new job nice
like uh like the king of prussia area
valley forge
yeah so i did that for like a few years
in elementary school and then back to
the bronx up in new york and i went to
fordham
like an idiot in the hood so yeah been
new york through and throws god forsaken
city but it's not
[ __ ] dead and i think it's ridiculous
i mean i'm sure there are some places
that are you know
not great right now but otherwise i mean
i know you're probably not supposed to
say this but i kind of like it
it is dude there's no [ __ ] tourists
walking around it's it's
all the outdoor seating it's not it's
crap cocktails outside
and people are like oh there's so many
homeless people i'm like what there's so
many homeless people before anyway we're
talking about it yeah yeah it's just
there's now less people on the street so
they seem
they seem a little more outnumbered
right yeah right a little more brazen
too
yeah they don't get [ __ ] yeah they run
up on the car pretty quick too steal
your appetizer if you're not
i mean like it's just came with five
bucks for those sticks there's only
three what's
going on i'm not paying for empty muscle
shells over here
holy [ __ ] city island i was i was
thinking montauk [ __ ] the hamptons
no man it's uh yeah city island's a
weird spot where it's like
uh you know a lot of people show up for
dinner yay
big mother's day spot orange spot uh
and then but then if you live there it's
kind of weird you know what i mean it's
like imagine so were you a beach kid
like is there
you know it's funny i'm from uh like
everybody i know growing up is like
fishermen and boats and all that [ __ ]
and i just i never really did that
so i'm like it doesn't make sense that
i'm from seattle
i've seen it on a bourdain show it looks
like [ __ ] deadliest catch
there's like a lot of boats a lot of
docks yeah there's it's funny people
you know yeah they're they're fishing in
the long island sound they got boats
it's nice but you would they would they
think of themselves as you know the
deadliest catch and it's like
you're just catching some like toxic
blue fish from the sound you know
that's what i love too i mean all these
fishing off a bridge yeah
there's you know traffic to get on the
island on sundays or mother's day or
whatever
it can take like legitimately like 45
minutes to get on this island to have
seafood that i'm like either you're
eating from the sound that is disgusting
yeah or it's been in the freezer for me
it's not fresh seafood you idiot for
sure yeah so tony allen clamps
exactly man i love the move too i find
that a lot of people that are that are
not from philly
they describe if their dad got
transferred it's always for like a year
or two
nobody wants to be there that's not a
final destination
yeah it's a layover right it was funny
though coming from city island uh we
kind of had like a two family apartment
situation and then
we got to philly and yeah burbs are
philly yeah
pool and a huge backyard and all this
like suburban [ __ ]
clean living there yeah ain't nothing
wrong with the king of prussia mall
either i'll tell you that dude that was
that's a [ __ ] hand imagine the orange
julius [ __ ] stretch the legs
that was the one that was always far
from us that was like that was like an
hour but i remember like we'd go once a
year and it was like multiple
levels there was an elevator we were
like what dude it was like going to
disneyland just running around
i walked that place for hours you're
like there's two food courts one
[ __ ] enthusiasm as a fat kid it blew
your [ __ ] smell the rock and roll the
second you walk in there
there's a sizzler like right around the
corner from it yeah that's great
great did anybody if you're listening to
this and you've taken
a mass trip to the mall once a year with
your family like that
multiple cars you're [ __ ] yeah
garbage yeah for sure we did it every
[ __ ] christmas like four or five cars
shoplift presents for each other caravan
coming through
stealing bras from your mom switching
receipts [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] so where did you guys so you
were down there in the bird where did
you go to school do you remember
how elementary we talked valley forge
elementary school you went to valley
forge elementary and then
i did like a year so this is pretty
trashy i did so
uh transfer is never a good one yeah how
did it play out so so i'm
i'm in philly or again on the burbs and
i i'm at valley forge middle school this
is fifth grade
and then um so my grandfather my mom's
dad gets sick and we uh
move to back to the bronx to kind of be
with the family sure
and uh he had you know a prognosis
supposed to be he's supposed to live
longer than he did
okay he died pretty quickly and then we
moved back
to philly and we didn't tell the other
school
that i was leaving so all of a sudden my
dad once got a phone call being like so
your son has been like absent for like a
hundred years straight days
his kids missed three months in school
what the [ __ ] you doing and i'm like
bouncing back and forth between
schools i'm like hey i'm back i feel
like what the [ __ ] is going on yeah
uh but i will say eventually after we i
came back to new york permanently
and we moved to westchester i'll pelham
and but i was the kid from the bronx
and he got a little bit of an edge to
you i mean the girls were loving it the
guy's like who the [ __ ] is this dude
meanwhile city it's like karate kid [ __ ]
rolling up to a new school
guys don't like it chicks
you know city islands like the fake
bronx you know i call it the francs it's
like
it's a weird place but it's not like you
know you're not you're not telling them
no way i was like yeah you know there
was a couple like drive-bys
there's some drugs nothing big deal
that's how we do it where i'm from i
don't know what to tell you
you keep turning and talking to the
camera all the time
that's just what we did back at city
island that's how we roll you know
i would have loved that i would have
played that up oh yeah give or kill
anybody
yeah i mean the only time i've ever been
confused for a tough guy
or anything in my whole life was then
dude i think every teenage kid would
have did the same
exact sure you keep that close to the
vet all of a sudden i got an
uh accent know get throwback jerseys
let's go
i'm a rapper guys i'm working on my demo
right now
holy [ __ ] all right so let's focus uh
let's focus on that a little bit i like
that so you finally got into
settled into a suburban situation for
high school pelham was that a single
family home
uh no so at that point everybody you
know back together uh so it's me i got
an older brother who works with me at
barcelo younger sister so we were all
kind of like a broken family for a
minute but then back together
but you guys were living in a single
family house oh yeah once we're back
yeah yeah yeah like a
suburban house yes yeah uh but even that
was like you know pelham's like a nice
town and we bought like
you know the shittiest house on the
block to dress it up
you know big time mansion our house i
remember we pulled up i'm in like
seventh grade and my mom's like here's
our new home
and it was some like old chick lived
there and it was so overgrown
couldn't couldn't see the house yeah it
was just like trees and bushes and
that's always a tough one let's go back
to the hood
yeah is it stupid you're really going on
faith with that because you're a little
kid and your parents like we're moving
it's not like you're sitting on the
[ __ ] the real estate yeah you just
you'd show up and you
go pick a room it's like pick a room
i'll take the [ __ ] hampton inn down
the street
i'm not [ __ ] getting my mail here
[ __ ] all
up i still got the p.o box right ma did
your old man
they cleaned it all up though is he yeah
does he take care of the yard so they're
uh they're back on city island now so
they they like downgraded it and
got out of uh pelham my dad is was very
uh like
fishy here this kid's moving around a
lot what the [ __ ] your dad do
jesus so he he was very handy uh in his
younger
younger age very like he could build
[ __ ] and electrical
he ran the empire state building for a
while dang it like that's ran it that's
uh
not garbage yeah yeah that's a [ __ ]
new york institution maybe like the uh i
guess like this
chief operating officer or whatever yeah
so hopefully there was like this billion
you ever watched the jinx yeah so the
durst family owns
uh a lot of property yeah like so prior
to the empire state building he was
working with the durst and he was like
the non-billionaire of the group and
then he got the job at empire state
building kind of ran the operations of
it all
okay pretty sweet now you went to high
school out there was it public or
private public
public i've always been a public guy
pelham bay high wasn't it memorial high
school
that's not bad yeah pretty classy yeah
we were you know it's like so pelham's
like in between new rochelle the bronx
mount vernon and then like
in the middle is is this like wannabe
fancy town
yeah yeah i know i've performed to tell
them a couple of years yeah there's a
there's a wonderful establishment
they're right uh the rock
rockwell yeah that's right whoo spent a
month there one night
shout out to tommy at rockwell like a
fuddruckers great wings though
oh dude that's the best part of you know
how you know you know you know a gig is
bad when you're like how isn't they go
the food's [ __ ]
awesome dude you get out there like two
hours early they feed you it's
free beers all night i get on that like
11 59 train back to the city all tuned
up
and that's so trashy too you saying that
great wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait you're garbage i also tell them uh
it's my birthday so that i get the
waffle with the ice cream
dude dude that's a that's a question
that is the trashiest thing to do the
fake birthday oh
man i tried to get a free slice of
cheesecake or something i remember
waiting table people come in and be like
do they do anything for your birthday
take a hike baseball hats i think if
you're a guy over the age of 21 and you
celebrate a birthday
span kick rocks maybe for 30 you give
them like a nod or something but
i know i i had friends who were like
planning a group
joint birthday for like 31. kill
yourself
dude i'll do a bar hey i'm going to be
here saturday night drinking whoever
comes comes
yeah let's get a little cash for mom and
dad maybe a nice dinner maybe a little
loop i don't know we'll see what happens
fingers crossed keep it [ __ ] moving
all right well let's play a little
[ __ ] argue garbage
how garbage if garbage you are
we'll see uh let's center on like i said
let's go back to pelham
uh we'll hit you with some of the basics
that we like to ask what was the name of
the street
that you grew up on very not garbage
okay
witherby avenue
on the corner of um uh uh brook
brook something meat that's brookville
or bronze brookville it was some
bougie dude it could have been on the
corner of dead end avenue that still
sounds nice can we get some champagne in
here
that's good that might be the best
answer we've got holy [ __ ] that's like
that's like fake name territorial sure
my name is tripp witherby
the trip whether it be with sports
that's pretty pretty good what about the
grocery store where would your mom shop
um there was a uh uh sea town de chico's
the chico's did you see town yeah it was
nice
trash big time trash yeah sea town's no
bueno i i i feel like
in recent years maybe there's like a
like a trader joe's or some [ __ ] nearby
but yeah it was like a local chain it
wasn't like a whole foods type [ __ ] it
was trash
trash you had us with the name of the
street droppings yeah dropping quick
though
and it was like you could you could see
like
almost like bootleg commercials on tv
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i think sea towns are individually owned
as well oh you know what else even more
trash there was the grastedes
oh those are terrible understand i think
that grassheads is a drug front
you think i mean i used to go there and
there was like nobody there yeah their
aisles are like i can barely fit their
hands too [ __ ] grab the scene stop
screaming
that's the place where like you actually
have to check the milk expiration
because it might actually be
there's like dust on the macaroni and
cheese hand written the date's hand
written on it like wait a minute that's
like a bad bodega
all right kippy what do you got all
right so did you have a at the house in
pelham did you have a garage
uh yes all right this is a big one this
is big
did you uh have a garage fridge in that
garage
no we had like a piece of [ __ ] garage it
was it was not attached it was separate
okay but it was all nice it was but it
was like a glorified
shed okay we didn't park our cars in it
or anything it was more just like just
like
garbage so no second fridge that just
had beverages or beers
we had a uh oh we had this is trash here
we go we had a basement
okay this is shaping up to be good
pseudo
furnished i like old couches and [ __ ]
definitely not you know like carpet and
nice [ __ ] but like we did we did
we threw up we had a pool table cool
okay full size
nope ah come on and a little like
crooked
i'm trying to
[Laughter]
like hang out in the basement even
though it was really it wasn't really
nice uh and we did have a second fridge
that we it was like our meat
fridge okay that's good yeah one day
though uh i was
you know trying to like i said trying to
hang out there so i'm unplugging things
and plugging in like a boom box or
whatever the [ __ ] it was no
left the meat fridge on ruined the week
mom and pop's
not happy about that holy [ __ ] that was
tough three nights worth of [ __ ]
steaks in there i gotta go back to seat
omaha steaks all just [ __ ] done
that's a question are you omaha steaks
family
huge oh dude if you're getting mal via
the [ __ ] cancel the champagne you're
gonna meet via the post office you
[ __ ] up somewhere
promo code kfc all right get the
father's day package year round
let the kid wet his beak will ya i'll
tell you what my aunt
i like it i know i get what you're
saying mailing getting stakes in the
middle of trash
of the summer my aunt had just sent us
down like a little care package
she used to do hickory farms back in the
day remember them mm-hmm we'd get one of
those that would show up
salami or whatever yeah with a little
strawberry candies in the fake grass
that's what you swear that's what you
said when someone dies dude you're just
getting them on a tuesday
that's real trash here's some pork wine
if you guys the best it's like see
somebody dies it's like here's a ham
yeah yeah yeah thanks man yeah the love
of my life but at least i have poor
people
yeah at least i got a sweaty ham to look
after and go get a honeywell spiral
uh but no we got a bunch of [ __ ] from
omaha steaks the steaks were [ __ ]
awesome and they also sent
like hot dogs or sausages
uh a big thing is do you keep the cooler
that it comes in and reuse it
i mean we got six of those in our garage
that's garbage
i can confidently say i i don't i have
not done that i have saved the uh
ice packs oh yeah yeah come on you're
not a [ __ ] jerk
oh yeah you're twisting it yeah
all right i don't i disagree with that
because those coolers that they send
are pretty they're they're pretty good
foam coolers they're like yes you're
trying to get rid of a body dude
no way that that you should not be
putting anything in the beach with that
thing man like it's a yeti or something
yeah yeah
and the thing is they don't have a big
handle on it you're drinking out of it
you gotta duct tape it together
those yetis man my parents both have
them they walk around like they're
[ __ ] tumblers or what are they called
the rockers
i feel like if you it's like a cult yeah
it's like a big gulp with [ __ ]
with the handle on it it's like it's
just either it's a cooler or a cup or
something it's not the end of the world
yeah
give it a rest the branding's working
though
big time that was a great phrase you
ever see that or just
hot chicks sitting on a yeti and like a
thong they're called yeti butts like
that's pretty
uh you know keep it simple stupid i like
it we gotta we gotta get a better
marketing department dylan what the [ __ ]
you doing there
holy [ __ ] all right so we got that
no garage fridge but freezer downstairs
even though you ruined it
that's uh that's all right um
i got i got one let me take this because
we this is this was a big one last week
first
do you brush your teeth in the shower oh
yeah no thank you what
thanks we've been arguing about this or
just yelling about this on the podcast
the idea that people are like it's a
life hack
have you seen that yes no it's [ __ ]
gross you don't feel fresh coming out of
there with your teeth brushed that's a
different thing the people who are like
it's gonna save
time it's like no it's not there's not a
good argument you'll have to and first
of all it's gonna
max save what 30 seconds well you can't
do you can't do this
you're just standing there brushing your
teeth which you would be doing in the
bathroom anyway but here's the thing if
you do it you know
if you do it in the shower that saves on
the splash on the [ __ ] mirror
and all the toothpaste that gets in the
sink i mean what do you do when you
brush your teeth
you just like spitting it out what are
you doing [ __ ] gets loose
i mean by the way uh the idea that
you're supposed to brush for two full
minutes is insanity have you ever tried
to do that
yeah it's like i'm there for half an
hour it's like washing your hands doing
happy birthday choice
get the [ __ ] out of here i don't know
how my teeth are still in my head me too
well i can see from here there's a
couple not in there
the only these being fake i think is the
only thing that saved me i haven't got
to the dentist in
oh i've been there decades i want to i
want a decade and i went i just went
like six months ago or like probably
eight months ago clean
like good yeah goodbye she tried to like
sell me on some serve it was it was a
weird it was a weird it was like a
groupon one that like my girlfriend or
my wife got me
there's a slipper no no i guess she was
my girlfriend at the time
out there on city island yeah i feel
like if i do go to the dentist they're
going to be like well you have about
like 35 cavities it's not as
and i somebody else did the same thing
and told me they're like it's not as bad
as you think
you're going to go you got like one
cavity or whatever i was clean bill she
tried to sell me some [ __ ] service i
was like hit this
flossing or something weird like i lost
uh
just the other day for like i do i do
like a semi-annual floss that's the one
that's the one thing i'm really good at
i've lost two yeah yeah like twice
a day because i wanted to wear it
literally twice a year
i get so much [ __ ] in my teeth that like
i don't feel i don't like if i go to bed
i'll have like a little piece of meat or
something like that
yeah then you gotta do it i mean i i did
my semi-annual floss and it looked like
i i went 12 rounds
it smells so bad
i don't know how dennis do that [ __ ]
just scraping they're always giving you
so you must be uh brushing twice a day
if you're doing it
i'm pretty good about you twice a day
i'm a good
let's call it like ten times a week it's
probably not twice a day it's probably
like ten times yeah
i'm like night time this is pretty
garbage i just you know i'm going to bed
yeah me too
i'm going to sleep i'm not trying to
impress anybody i'll brush them in the
morning
this is trashy sometimes when i get up
in the morning i like to wait to brush
them because i like that taste
oh sometimes i don't know why all right
dude you always go a little too far
quite a b i thought we were in the trust
tree here
being honest yeah what about this
because i i was thinking about the
the brushing teeth in the shower how do
you both feel about
the brushing of the teeth but you're
walking around the apartment a little
bit
are you are you okay with that i don't
know right now right in front of the
sink
what do you first of all walk out see
what's on the news how long are you
brushing
you are i'm a big walker see that's
trash small apartment but a big walker
once i'm in the kitchen i'm in the
closets i'm everywhere for what maximum
60 seconds yeah i don't know why it's
just my brain shuts off and i just gotta
go i also wanna i i maybe i don't
maybe i'm not a quantity guy but i'm a
quality with the brush
and if i'm in the middle of my living
room there's you know forget it
it's like i got it what's your
toothpaste of choice these days
crest 4d white whatever right yeah
you've got
an aristocrat that's the one yeah i
don't even know what the [ __ ]
i didn't even know there's a fourth
dimension [ __ ] elon musk makes that
[ __ ] interstellar over here i picked
it up in a black hole
ah that's good all right uh i got one
there
uh i wanted to ask you this what'd you
get in your sats
uh oh it's a gold one um 13
20. what yeah it's not hard you've got a
brain on it yeah i did it was exactly
uh 660 and 660. like yeah verbal of math
and where'd you go to school did you go
to college yeah
[Music]
philly and i had like two of my best
friends for life
i met there i love cheese steak so i was
like let me go back
and villanova was like the idea and i
thought i was going to get in and when i
didn't i was just like
i guess i'll go to florida my brother
went to fordham yeah it was really not
like i wanted to go there it was kind of
just like ah [ __ ] it let's just do it
yeah yeah
that's [ __ ] that's that's it that's
me that's the main line that's [ __ ]
nice yeah that was the uh once i didn't
get in i was like villain no fun this
place sucks even though i desperately
wanted to go
i love you guys yeah my uncle was the
soccer coach there for a long time
oh yeah i used to spend a bunch of time
out there yeah but yeah 16 uh
13 20 out of the 1600 that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] pretty impressive
i'll take it you're gonna take any lsats
or anything like that uh no
i did oh i [ __ ] i can't i got an mba
oh yeah i saw that from where from
boredom it was kind of a fake one though
that's my whole life is fake until you
make it so you made it daddy
keep doing it i graduated early
and and did a five-year program oh so
like so i had a couple i did some ap
credits i took some summer courses so i
was
i was caught i work ahead yeah um like
yeah there was one summer where i didn't
i i didn't had surgery and i uh i didn't
have a job so i just did school and then
i was able to always register early for
classes
so i kind of scammed the whole system
and then uh they said i had the grades
for this mba program
so rather i graduated semester early
okay and so then
i should have graduated in may like with
normal people for an undergrad
i graduated that same august with an mba
so i like you know i hustled that that's
a [ __ ] mover and [ __ ]
took that and i flushed it down
to become a smut peddler yeah exactly so
that's bluechew.com everybody
has nothing to shake a stick at that's a
really good school yeah it got the job
i mean if i had if i could do it all
over again i would go elsewhere
yeah my cousin got in there and she was
all excited then she got into boston
college and she was like
patios i mean my first my first my
freshman year i got
like right away i got mugged at gunpoint
really got into my neck
that's tough i was like what am i doing
here like why did i do this why didn't i
go to like arizona state
i know was one of the kids from
westchester found out you weren't really
tough
it was it was it was me my buddy you
[ __ ]
it was me my buddy and uh and this girl
we went out it was like a tuesday night
we're walking back to the dorm we i was
i could see like the security guard i
wanted to be like
hey yeah he's like sleeping in the in
the booth yeah
literally he was like right around
christmas and uh he grabbed the girl
and he's like you know hey baby i need i
need christmas presents so like give me
all your money
and she was a little drunk and she was
about to start mouthing off and i was
like
do not say that i got you right here i
got you right here yeah so then he
grabbed me and
put the gun on my neck and he walks away
with like seven dollars but you know
traumatized for life so
damn yeah gun to the neck that's tough
man hardcore
and you you mentioned asu that's always
that's like every east coast [ __ ]
knuckleheads plan
because like back then it was like the
number one party school like playboy it
was they were the number one and
something
and every dude was like [ __ ] this
whether i'm going out there asu
i legit can't imagine what your life is
like when you know your dorm is like a
pool like
yeah i think asu has a lazy river or it
had a lazy river
on campus i'm telling my son i'm going
to give him a choice of like five
schools when he's older
and that's it and there none of them are
going to be good schools you know it's
like you're going to a big time football
school
or warm weather school yeah yeah when i
was a kid
playable used to have those uh you know
the hottest girls of the yeah the scc or
whatever
holy [ __ ] that was [ __ ] the best i
want to go there i want to go there i
want to go there
and then instead i go to the hood for
something yeah i went to temple so it
was the same thing it was like in the
middle i mean dude it was
[ __ ] no calendar down there chubby
white dude from the burbs ends up in
north philly
that was a [ __ ] eye opener a lot of
sweatpants worn inside out down there
not classy how do you feel about the
filet of fish sandwich
uh i'm out on that thank you thank you
big
time out on that uh i i uh
at the same i mean i do eat garbage food
but i just i think i draw the line at
the fish
something about me feels like the fish
needs to be somewhat fresh or whatever
what about the uh what about the
imitation crab meat
how do you feel about that uh give me
like an example like uh
with the spoon like are we talking like
straight from friday night
like [ __ ] look at him he's got some
on him if you need it
pull it out under a roll or something
here you go i got some for later
i'm talking friday night you went to the
store dude uh maybe the lady's out doing
something with her friends and you pick
up a little [ __ ] grocery store
seafood salad
which is now 18 to each their own
i i i really can't talk with you 13 20
he's not eating [ __ ] imitation crab
meat
jerk off i'm a garbage person when it
comes to food those i mean uh
entamons is my jam that's classy what
are you doing
okay all right then if that is classy
then i am the [ __ ] queen of england
what's your move on enemies uh i have uh
the rich
chocolate frosted donuts come on here's
the thing i take it
very seriously lay it on here what i
call of course we have what i call
donut season i do not eat donuts i do
not eat the entrance donuts
in the warm weather months no you can't
and the people who say put it in the
fridge
i want to light them on fire yeah get
the [ __ ] out of it ruins it from from so
from like
the chocolate gets too hard yeah and
it's like a little too waxy right in the
fridge
i go like october to april
this guy's got a good [ __ ] head on
the shoulder the snap the crunch a
little bit
oh and and they have four different
variations they've got the full size the
pop bets the pop bums the minis
are amazing they're the full i remember
i i still remember the first time i had
a full size while my stepmom brought
them home and i was like what
i told my mom i said yo tuts step it up
yeah
she's [ __ ] coming for the crown over
here the crumb cake ugh i love the
crunch
and i just cake i just cut the middle
piece out right away like a piece of
[ __ ]
yeah uh i mean anything entenman's i'm
i'm really wrong i do a fudge cake where
the [ __ ] fudge is like [ __ ] three
inches thick it's [ __ ]
great yeah they got a case at the end of
the aisle
all right since we're on food i have one
for you we're big uh
like popping in and grabbing like a beer
and an appetizer it's big for us you
know what i mean if you're somewhere you
pop in grab a beer an appetizer i enjoy
it
so one of uh you know i have a menu from
one of america's fine dining
establishments known as
tgi fridays okay
thankfully not a uh an applebee's i'm
banned from applebee for a while yeah
that's garbage wait wait wait wait wait
but i
like it uh we went to uh i guess maybe
just this specific location
we were in maine we already got his
picture on every [ __ ] door
we were in maine for uh tobogganing some
crazy parcel show we were doing sure and
we go to uh applebee's and
they are very strict about how much
alcohol you can consume really
so the point that like it's absurd
though like we were there for like six
hours because we were trash people
and uh they you know we ordered like
another round and they're like you know
we can't do it and
and i i think the rule is like you can't
have more than like four drinks in an
hour or whatever it is and they were
pointing to the cameras like they're
watching
so we left hey what the [ __ ] yeah
exactly like a big brother or some [ __ ]
so we left and changed clothes really
came back thinking that they were going
to like not notice and they were like
not noticing six drunk [ __ ]
i still have my tablet open right i went
from like a red shirt to a blue shirt
it's like bobby valentine trying to
[ __ ] hide in the dugout so
uh yeah okay tgi it's real [ __ ] trash
but i love it that's a power move
dude there's nothing better than being
in a place where you're not really
supposed to be drunk and being drunk
literally ordered every thing one of
everything i love it's so good
um so this is that jack daniel sauce god
damn it
this is the tti friday's appetizer
menu let me know your top two picks
okay all right jew couple of buddies
couple of beers
you got your mozzarella sticks you got
your spinach and artichoke dip
you got your chips and salsa but if
you're getting chips and salsa on
[ __ ] fridays hit the [ __ ] that's
freaking lame uh you got warm pretzels
which i must be a new addition to the
menu i never saw that
you got pan-seared pot stickers pork
dumplings there you go
green bean fries what that what friday
signature whiskey glazed sesame chicken
strips
panko crusted we got the winner
uh loaded potato skins
and friday's signature whiskey glazed
sliders
okay all right first of all starting off
mozzarella sticks 100
sure i mean that they got a mean
mozzarella couple
yeah anywhere by the way like that's you
know mozzarella you gotta go monsters
what's the slot is this a burger slider
uh it's usda choice beef burgers
signature whiskey glaze roasted onions
white cheddar and spicy mayo
with a tabasco chipotle pepper sauce
totally served with seasoned fries by
the way what gordon ramsay take that
place
yeah you know i almost would rather just
prefer like a cheeseburger yeah
that's a little bit too much that's a
little too much for her i'm going with
them for sure
but yeah i think ultimately that my pick
would be mozzarella sticks and sliders
uh what's up with the green bean fries
who are you trying to be stop get out of
here try to be
you just be garbage yeah everybody shut
up
right it's not a replacement [ __ ] off no
wings there huh no just like buttons no
nachos
no wings no nachos i think nachos are
overrated what
i think nachos are kind of a mess
because the problem is
i understand if you make you know
sometimes they make them like individual
uh portions with everything on it but
when you just get a pile it's tough
it's not you know you get one with all
your sour cream yeah
yeah yeah yeah i actually have an answer
for that uh believe it or not
what they should be doing is they should
be doing deconstructed notches right
where all the [ __ ] is in one thing and
then you get your chips on the side
yeah because uh the olive tree on
mcdougall street used to do nachos like
that
they would send out the chips and the
cheese and the chili
but everything else was on this like
accoutrement plate on the right
it's almost like fondue in a way
you know hey we're french over here you
said that like such new york garbage
almost like
sticks and i love a good load of
potatoes oh wow that the the mick in me
was
was leaning towards that we were talking
about the potato famine the other day
yeah i saw you got some [ __ ] we got a
lot of i mean i just
a million people died because we
couldn't make potatoes anymore yeah it's
crazy
i don't know if this paints a picture my
sister once asked me uh what animal do
potatoes come from
which i i don't think she got at 13 20
i'll tell you that much
and why you went to nyu i was a nurse
and everything i'm like listen
damn just remember your nurses frontline
heroes they might be stupid like my
sister
holy [ __ ] wow wow the appetizer menu
i like that i know i'm gonna make that
one i also like i'm a guy who who will
just order like several appetizers
instead of an entree yeah
of course i'm a huge i i i went through
a thing especially when i first had my
uh kids
where you're up at all hours at all
times i go i have
first meal second meal third meal i
don't call it breakfast lunch dinner i
eat
what i want when i want i'll have a
burger for breakfast i'll have cereal
for
dinner like i don't care yeah yeah
that's yeah that's my wife says that
she's like well
i'm like it doesn't matter it's it's
food i'm eating the cheese steak
oh yeah right don't matter if it's the
first meal of the day right how do you
feel about breakfast for dinner you're a
big fan of that huge
it's a trash meal but so trash so good
so trash but it's uh it's pancakes at
six o'clock it's just
like sears syrup on everything
yeah yeah yeah sausage links or sausage
patties
interesting questions it's a question i
think it's easier
kfc here's the deal the you're talking
breakfast sausage pack correct yeah
because there's rice
sausage and peppers is a different story
but we're doing but they also do like
you know sweet or hot italian patties
that you can have like on the grill
fantastic but the sausage patty
rolls cake but they are harder to find
the only place i know to get it
consistently
is [ __ ] mickey d's big breakfast yeah
those are
white and i do like the i guess it's uh
is it jimmy dean but there's like a
maple
yeah yeah small links yeah yeah i don't
like the big like gray links you get
like a diner like the big ones yeah
you're like i ordered this medium bunny
this thing's still [ __ ] bleeding yeah
but i'll do like the syrup infused
little links or the patty yeah they got
a good snap to them too
a little crisp get some when we get out
of here
all right um who did the cooking growing
up your mom and your dad
um my mom did the cooking very
begrudgingly like she [ __ ] hates
cooking and she'd be like i gotta keep
you sons of [ __ ] alive i guess
but we were a big time london broil mac
and cheese
wow uh burgers and chicken like rotate
the three over and over and over again
the london broil why did we think that
we thought that was funny
because it has the name london society
road dude that's a [ __ ] comeback
i don't even know what [ __ ] what cut
that is yeah where where is that even uh
i don't even know what animal we're
eating london uh we also had we did a
pork chops we called it pork chops and
red slop
bizarre like family meal check please
and it was like
uh i don't know if my mom like invented
it or not i don't know if it's a special
thing to our family but it was like some
sort of
onion red not like marinara but like
some sort of red
sauce that was like mix it up with the
pork chops it sounds eastern european
did you still do it does she
still whip it up dude now if i if it was
like i'm starving to death ma you need
to cook for me she should be go [ __ ]
yeah go [ __ ]
you i'll plan the i'll plan the funeral
go get a big breakfast she's not she's
not she's not cooking anymore did any
any of that translate over into how you
operate today
i mean i order food every single night
yeah that's right that's a new york
thing yeah
i mean i i can i could do the basics i'm
not you know
not gordon ramsey like you said earlier
i you know and on the grill i can
i can you know i can grill you up some
dogs and burgers and [ __ ] but i'm not
i'm by no means a cook
but you're and you're married now right
divorced okay so you're living by
yourself you're you're you're a single
guy all right so i'll have like cookies
for dinner yeah okay
all right yeah i thought i thought you
had a family i got i got two kids
uh they're with me you know half the
time so i it's a weird like you know
i'll have like my dad hat on and i'm
trying to like cook for them and be a
normal store yeah and then when they go
home
it's funny yeah yeah yeah wheels are
yeah the wheels come off ordering from
[ __ ] tony
dinopoly's getting the [ __ ] menu sign
up i'm a big tony d's guy
dude i ate there last night it's like
family style except i'm just eating it
myself
and so i when i first moved to new york
uh back back in like
in 2000 and then i moved back home when
i first came up here i tried to get a
job there
and they the they also own this shitty
chicken place called dallas barbecue oh
yeah yeah oh yeah that's
very familiar i tried to get a job at
this [ __ ] nice italian place
and they're like ah you're thinking
you're more of a they're more of a baby
it was in times square yeah the worst
thing the barbecue joint in times square
has to be
[ __ ] devastating it's terrible
frightening [ __ ] downtown syria it
was not a [ __ ] good environment
gang everyone's going through a hard
time right now and we've got the cure
of course we're talking about dick at
yourdoor.com
come on baby the absolute best let's
face it gang everyone's bummed out right
now so why not send your loved ones or
your enemies some delicious chocolate
decks fantastic i mean who knows this
might be the one thing to keep your
grandma alive
you know what i mean i've been a long
time she hasn't seen a real one in a
little bit
definitely keep her on her toes you know
what i mean nah now wake up
guys dick at yourdoor.com makes 100
handcrafted chocolate in the shape of
dicks we ain't talking about mass
produced over here
handcrafted [ __ ] artisan you can send
them directly and anonymously
or grow some balls and put your name on
it they also make prank greeting cards
they make [ __ ] noises when you open them
up who doesn't want that also tag that
one with nana too
let her see a real one so check out dick
yourdoor.com and if you
if you use the code garbage you'll save
15
on possibly the most delicious chocolate
dick you'll ever have
in your mouth i wouldn't go that far
unfortunately we can't say the same
about nana
once again that's dickyourdoor.com and
use the code
garbage for 15 off now back
to the show um all right i got one
let's see do you sneak snacks into the
movies
it's very funny you bring this up that
is a trash
move no i am going if if you think
snacks in his trash i went to chinese
food
i think i was seeing that movie with
ryan gosling the man the moon the
he went to the moon or whatever it was
relatively recently it was like yeah
yeah
yeah
uh i went to on central avenue uh in
yonkers
pretty trashy to begin with and i
snuck several cheesy gordita crunches
into
i went to the taco bell drive through
ahead of time and i put three cheesy
gordita crunches in my uh
in my hoodie pocket yeah pouch and then
i go into the theater and it was this
bizarre
like 15 person theater very tiny
and there were children there and i
walked right out and i just made my
my my cheese already crunches in the
parking lot because i was like i can't
i'm a grown man i'm sitting next to
children
yeah and i'm going to be crunching and
[ __ ] you know and then like maybe
i don't know a couple months later i put
that hoodie on put my hands in my
pockets and there's just shredded cheese
the shredded lettuce on the car seat is
i was like this symbol of garbage
memories of my trash
you know my trash what were you doing go
to the movies in yonkers i mean i live
in mount vernon i'm like right around
the corner from there so i
uh you know frequent yonkers that you
can put that in the trash columns
i say i say there's no shame in that and
and the way i
justify that is i'm always gonna get
something there
but you don't want to be a [ __ ] jerk
off and get [ __ ] you know and what's
your movie
snack order that's very interesting
kevin uh question kevin i appreciate you
asking that what i like we just talked
about that i'm a [ __ ] pretzel and
cheese guy
kind of like a new for new ageish in my
mind like yes
2000's probably early 2000's right big
thing of popcorn
okay all right and a [ __ ] big ass
cherry coke
oh i hate cherries cherry coke root beer
cream soda dr pepper rather die
what's your go to what uh who is this
guy coca-cola classic
unless we're at mcdonald's and then you
gotta go sprite because it sets your
[ __ ] mouth on fire
i don't know what that sprite they do
there what do they it's like it's i've
read up on it it's actually kind of like
there's a reason
oh yeah so they they they uh they store
it in
uh uh like a steel tub rather like some
places do like bags
yeah they do the steel that keeps it
like kind of light to it
yeah and they uh and they uh have like
an extra like their syrup
the syrup is like a little bit different
and then they if you notice they got
that
that thick straw and the wide straw you
kind of like i didn't say it's
yeah it's got some [ __ ] strength to
it it doesn't collapse
right it's good for a shake yeah but
sometimes i prefer a thinner one for my
saudi
oh do you i like a good gulp full yeah
uh
this is a big this was a big thing last
week too it's uh america is split on
will you order no ice with your soda
no what yeah thank you no [ __ ] people i
want a warm soda
people do people because there's
anything else or something yeah it melts
people the people are writing cold
beverages what they do
communist kevin is what they are the
communists yeah they'll get no ice in
the drive-through of mcdonald's dr
drink half of it drive home and then put
ice in it when they get home
like a real [ __ ] animal i mean block
those people
that's not sad that's pre-crime
yeah i'm drinking it before it melts or
whatever you're worried about yeah yeah
how do you feel about i this is what i
i'm on the fence about that very
seriously i know
do you take the if you go to the
drive-through will you eat it in the car
do you take it home
uh i'll usually order an extra fry for
the car okay but then you go home
you go home and you eat yeah you eat at
home but i i
yeah i i start eating right away
i just i just don't go anywhere that's
far enough where like my meal is done
gotcha guys i'm also like i'm a big mac
guy so like
you can't eat that in the car that's not
right that's a mess not true i mean
anything's possible foley's got a pulley
system in his car you're a young kid you
got a lot to learn i'll tell you that
i could do two big macs i gotta get
yeah because i'm doing that impulsively
yeah and you know
i'm waiting for those endorphins to
[ __ ] start making me feel better
yeah i got i always get a [ __ ] extra
burger and i eat
eating a cheeseburger and driving around
oh i feel like
hemp like denzel in training day
i didn't know you got wet you're in the
office baby i'm telling you that
okay the wise man let's go what's your
what's your fast food
like i feel like that's a look into the
soul of a man what's your number one
fast food place
uh hands down
it's k it's uh chick-fil-a i mean it's
the best
this guy is the best chick-fil-a it's
based on it's based on
product it's based on scarcity it's i
mean
you're not all you had sunday you have
the [ __ ] played by the marketing machine
sir whatever but i mean it's good but
it's not like like
popeyes chicken sandwich versus the
chicken flavor chicken sandwich what you
like popeyes
all day yeah we gotta go yeah put the
[ __ ] popeyes on everywhere on every
block
maybe they're up by yonkers in city
island but i mean
there's not a lot of foot traffic in
front of it you know the problem is
chick-fil-a
does not you got to eat it on site
delivery i think it's the
best i go to mcdonald's i don't eat that
much but i will
i mean it's mcdonald's it's the
coca-cola that's what i mean when you
said hands down i thought you were gonna
go to mcdonald's because it's like
classic it's the go-to but i think uh
kfc is the best one i'm sorry kf7 as i'm
looking at you chick-fil-a's the best
what's yours uh i would probably go it's
a it's
it's probably mcdonald's for just like i
said like the growing up
nothing tastes you know what i just
ordered and i got him delivered to my
house his face just [ __ ] lit up by
the way
i ordered the batman forever
promotional mugs you know what i'm
talking about
from like 20 years ago from like 30
years where'd you find them
i uh i don't know how i wouldn't eat
those mcnuggets
i got the batman the riddler two-face
and uh
robin are they all faded and stuff i
don't know and they're like real glass
it was like back when promotional gifts
were yeah
we talked about those on a couple
episodes drinking out of those as a kid
man you
felt like you were coming in from like a
basketball game or something
and they are like kid-sized by the way
they're like
but i mean mcdonald's is what kind of my
thing i love but really
the cheesy gordita crunch to me is like
the number one like single individual
food item
and then i love wendy's so i mean those
would be my silver bronze of gold in
some sort of order you know
yeah not too long ago all right i had a
baconator
mm-hmm a couple of them did it [ __ ] you
up it was like two weeks vacation yeah
fantastic yeah you know it's great too
checkers checkers has a bacon burger
that will [ __ ]
are there any up here though they're
probably outside of the city i know one
in brooklyn
that's the only way that's the only
place i know one in queens and let me
tell you something you better [ __ ]
come heavy
it ain't [ __ ] shake shack i'll tell
you you got to [ __ ] have your head on
you better check your [ __ ] sticks
like pregame
working out [ __ ] go in there with
some war paint on
go in there in a gully soup so no one's
seen you got it on my hip you know
ah good [ __ ] all right we got we got a
few more minutes here i'm on the fence
man it's i'm a coin flip on garbage
i'm trying to i'll try to uh i'm a huge
above ground pool guy oh
nice so it's city island we had one
we had an above ground pool in city
island in philly we got bougie and we're
in grounds
welcome uh and then uh in in westchester
we we we did a bug ground i mean i uh
ingram i i i would go as far to say as i
prefer
yes sir because it's the world
whirlpools are okay i'll give you a
whirlpool but it's a trash mentality no
i mean
sure
if you have in-ground pool money and you
get an above-ground pool you are [ __ ]
dream yeah i probably write about that
my parents put a deck around there yeah
cause then it's like a fake in-ground
above ground
[Laughter]
there's no way zillow numbers are going
up terry's doing very well
uh did you ever have any road signs that
you stole and put in your room like a
stop sign or [ __ ]
a couple uh construction cones that was
always the trash bag
i do not enter or something like that we
as a crew of friends like we
i never really did it but we we would
steal a stop sign
frequently yeah that would be they would
put it back up like by the
morning oh yeah they moved quick those
downshifts that's what i know when
you're in a good township
i mean i remember thinking like it was
funny and then being like man you know
there was never like an accident we're
on the hook for like
murder you know [ __ ] grandmother it's
cool in the frat house though right dude
yeah
i mean a woman killed in uh i mean i i
was going to bars when i was like 15.
yeah north avenue in uh in new rochelle
you know we had a fake id
my brother's fake id he said he said he
was born in like 72.
sure and i'm going in there as like a 15
year old loved that man north avenue
north avenue
in north show was the underage drinking
capital of the world i don't know if
they still have those
like just like bars where it's like you
walk in and nobody's 21.
not everybody gives a [ __ ] yeah that was
the best dude not even close uh
so did the bars early i mean we drank in
the woods like every
high school you know kids did it's weird
because in
in a small weird way that is a major
life lesson because especially
sometimes those places weren't like just
a free-for-all but it was a place where
they looked the other way
and it would be like a place that like
sold pizza and they had beer
but they'd have like a little bar and it
would just be like a couple of like
old people sitting yeah it was like if
you were respectful we'll look the other
way yeah
you just hang out you start talking to
them and like when the [ __ ] would you as
a 15 year old kid would be talking to
some [ __ ]
you know 60 year old vietnam vet [ __ ]
you know telling a story learning some
life yeah learning some [ __ ] life
right no millennial [ __ ] i've been
talking to the nom vet since i was 15.
smoking cigs inside um
do you know the words to the final
battle scene in the movie eight mile
uh because if you do is is a game
changer yeah i mean i i'm not gonna be
able to do it for you right now yeah
i'll ask it but if we
put it on i'm getting my beat rabbit
it's mom's spaghetti
no doubt okay i went through a very big
like
i am a black person face dude every
white kid from the suburbs
100 wanted to be be rabbit yeah i mean
especially when i was playing basketball
in city island it was like me
and one other white kid named tommy
coakley and the restaurant tommy
oakley is a great name great name great
name tommy
there was i asked tommy came in
but yeah big time like wanted to be a
rapper and
you know wore big baggy clothes and
jordans and
[ __ ] like that you ever have any
throwback jerseys oh yeah yeah
embarrassingly sorry
actors i once uh wow i was at the king
of prussia mall
hit it and yeah i was out of models or
something and there was a jason kidd
mavericks jersey that was mispriced and
there was like 15.99 instead of like the
usual like 50 bucks
at the time with a big deal i mean but
it was a size like 52.
i bought it anyway and i'm just walking
around with a jason kid like nightgown
because it was 15 bucks instead real
trash yeah big time trash
we pl i don't know if this is
necessarily trashy or one way the other
i played magic the gathering as a kid oh
that's [ __ ] nerdy
nerdy not really trash not trash those
were good things
that leans towards classy yeah you know
you're talking about jason kidd remember
when the nets were good and like
everybody was wearing the nets jerseys
that none of that aged well at all those
jerseys were terrible those
that was good man if they didn't run
into the [ __ ] lakers they probably
would have won a couple
yeah what year was that that was
probably oh it was early
three-ish or something like that van
horn right wasn't he on that horn
hiddles kenya yeah he got in that tree
high socks he got in trouble with like
pre-paid call calling
that's a hustle right there before we
leave i want to follow through with a
couple of things because i am on the
fence as well and what's possible i can
think about it i can't
smoke guns it's like yes and then no yes
the things that especially with the food
the things that i eat which i'm [ __ ]
garbage is grossing you out and that
leads me to believe that you're classy
i just want to follow through a little
bit like how do you feel about
mayonnaise
love mayonnaise hellmann's or are you a
miracle whip guy
i mean he just looked at me he was gonna
[ __ ] get through i'm out of here
what a disrespect i'm not a miracle guy
i gotta ask the question where
i gotta follow through here i got a job
today i
am a hellman's guy good if if you talk
to other people at bar stool there are
some
high society folks who love like a nice
uh
charcuterie board they call me like the
trash
i'm the trash bin of like barstool like
i eat like a little kid to them
like cottage cheese um no not really
all right good you know i don't even
know what i would put that on or do with
it you know
is it a cheese is it a dessert i don't
know
yogurt i don't know shout out to
breakstones everybody i like cream
cheese
and sour cream i do that all right like
sour cream anything that
like if i'm doing sour cream i'm doing a
[ __ ] ton of it and when i do like a
bagel with cream cheese i want it to be
like a brick of cream cheese in the
middle you know
you know what my favorite thing in the
world is is when the cream cheese is in
the
in the hole you know what i mean and you
just take a bite of the cheese without
the
bagels that's a day changer yeah get
that in the morning that
well that is the [ __ ] that'll put a
little pep in your step on the way to
the office
you know it was a life-changing for me
too when they invented uh cannoli chips
i don't even know what the [ __ ] so
rather than like sitting there eating
like a cannoli dick you know
they just give you a tub of the cream of
course and then you just dip it yeah
cannoli
all right yeah man i was thinking of
canola i'm like what's the no no
yeah the chip's so good yeah but yeah if
you're if if food is where you're
leaning i will like hand up i probably
i would have to be honest with myself
and say i'm a trash food person here's
my final question for you all right
it is uh on the food line growing up
or now did you have milk with dinner
oh yeah oh
my god that's it
and cheese and like a pint glass of it
kfc radio baby
come on one of the milkman i love it
that's right that's it for you that's it
that's what put it over there
i don't know exactly what number but
you're in the you're in the trash half
my brother would eat uh craft singles
cheese with a bag of wise potato chips
yes
and a glass of milk that was his [ __ ]
snack i just made my blood run cold
he doesn't like it he thinks milk within
it for dinner is [ __ ]
psychopath [ __ ] i kind of i kind of like
grew out of it a little bit but every
now and then i'll do it like
i'll do like does it like meatballs and
spaghetti with that's basically [ __ ]
spaghetti everybody loves spaghetti i
mean i
i'll do milk uh with with some of those
old school meals and it just
when it's ice cold you feel it run
through your chest
that's it right there [ __ ] garbage
yeah yeah you were putting up a show
when you first came in i saw the legs
crossed at one point
sitting back and relaxing mac and cheese
and
glass of whole milk that's trash i love
it
i'm honored i'm honored buddy thank you
so much is there anything you want the
folks out there to know before you get
out of here uh we got a new app
out uh excellent answer the internet
yeah it's a it's a game that we uh we
took
all the questions that we've been asked
on our podcast for the last decade
and we put it into a card game that you
can also buy uh we turned it into a
youtube series with comics and
celebrities coming through answering
these
crazy hypothetical questions and now we
turned it into an app so you can
download the app for free
and you can buy uh decks of questions
very it's kind of like
we're coming for like the cards against
humanity correct and i feel like we're
kind of taking over that
that uh genre that market so download
the answer the internet app it's on uh
it's on the it's in the app store we
don't do the google play because
that's trash yeah yeah you got an
android you're pouring if you got green
text messages don't text me how about
that
keep it moving yeah what do you got for
him kim uh guys just again make sure you
rate review subscribe on itunes uh keep
us in the top 200 as well as
full video available and available on
youtube you can subscribe there
as well and i'm at kevin ryan comedy on
all social media
very nice nh foley and ice and foley
grams on instagram just want to do a
quick shout out to a couple special
listeners
shout out to brian and salisbury beach
and shout out to uh mr ryan patrick and
his girl
up there in columbus guys thank you so
much taking money
what the [ __ ] was that that's a first
somebody greasing you to do shout outs
let me let me they're either getting
paid or that someone's dying or
something that's going to make a wish or
something you know i never be nice to
the fans somebody else's
something's up i know you you're not
nice i know you hey we would love to
have you guys on uh casey
if you want to come by the barcelo
office too
thank you so much for doing the show
gang we will see you guys next time here
on are you garbage